just just explain exactly what the
concerns are of course
we understand the government the the
medical advisers the scientific advisors
have all pointed out we will see
infections rising after
july the 19th but it's the effect that
it might have on
on younger people that that is is
raising some concern
when we're talking about younger people
here we're talking about young
adults so people essentially over the
age of 20
and what we've been seeing in our data
and we're going to
be talking more about this in the next
couple of days is that
even younger people in the ages of 20 to
50 are suffering kidney injuries
and liver injuries during the acute
phase of covid
and some of these will lead to lifelong
problems
many of these will get better on their
own but in themselves
these show that covert isn't just a flu
virus it's actually causing damage to
other parts of the body they're actually
quite significant
what's what what surprised us now is
that these injuries aren't just
associated with frail and elderly people
which death in from covert absolutely is
uh and we're instead seeing these in
much younger age groups
essentially the people who have survived
covet are getting damaged
do we have any ideas as to why that
might be
the case why there would be this this
effect on
a group of people that you know we all
look at rather enviously
as being young attractive fit and
healthier than than you or i
except these are the ones that have come
into hospital so they've
they've had it bad they have been the
unlucky ones that have had it severely
it does it does go to show that you can
be unlucky and just because you're young
doesn't mean that you're invincible it
emphasizes the need for vaccination
because
the other surprising feature of this
research is that
severity at admission to the hospital is
one of the stronger predictions of
your likelihood of having a complication
that means that your
pathway to having that complication was
set in the tablet of stone before you
came to hospital
which means it's less likely that what
we do in hospital will
prevent that injury not to say that
we're useless uh we have got good drugs
and good treatments
it's just that if you know that the
disease severity at the front door is
predicting the outcome you've got to do
something to people before they get to
hospital
and the best thing to do is to prevent
the disease in the first place
and that means vaccination so wrapping
this all up it means that vaccination is
still going to be the way out of this
even for the younger people under the
age of 50. i i i
i don't want to be putting words into
your mouth but i'm taking it from what
you're saying there that
in terms of those that we're seeing in
hospitals suffering kidney disease
suffering that scarring on the lungs
in the main those are people who have
not been vaccinated either once or twice
here i particularly know that we're
going into wave three
where uh i'm trying to get this off the
top of my head but i think it's about 88
of people in hospital haven't either
either haven't been vaccinated or
have been vaccinated so recently that
the vaccine hasn't had a chance to work
so yeah it's a bit of a no-brainer now
where
the evidence is overwhelming that
vaccination is
highly protective are there any concerns
professor you simply
you know the data on this but are there
any concerns for those under
that age group that we've been
discussing the young people of 20 years
and over
are we seeing anything similar in terms
of kidney disease
lung scaring other problems amongst
people
who are under the age of 20. so that
kind of analysis
is ongoing i am aware of a research
group that is
going to publish shortly or has just
published today it's going to be the
next
day or so about a very small number of
children having some
problems with their brains on the whole
children are not severely affected by
covert
death rates in children from covert
running around about one in a million to
two in a million uh
probably closer to one in a million so
very
very far fewer children affected but
they do get this
multi-system inflammatory disorder now
again it's
small numbers but it does show that the
virus can get
into other parts of the body than just
the lungs
professor count simple as always thanks
very much for being with us